on this first day of february
journalists in mexico are mourning the
murder of yet another colleague the
fourth to be killed since the start of
this year mexico city ranks as one of
the most dangerous places in the world
for journalists reporters are being
targeted for exposing corruption at the
top the murders have sparked angry
protests and the government is under
pressure to make it safer for
journalists to do their job
journalist roberto toledo was preparing
to record an interview when he was shot
he died from his wounds in hospital
the director of the online paper toledo
worked for monitor michoacan said the
team had been receiving death threats
for months
today those threats became concrete
exposing corrupt administrations and
corrupt officials and politicians today
led to the death of one of our
colleagues
toledo's killing follows those of three
other mexican journalists in january
2022 alone
one of them was reporter lord maldonado
lopez
she was found shot dead in her car
in the border city of tijuana
in 2019 she had appealed to mexico's
president obrador himself after becoming
involved in a dispute with a prominent
politician and media owner
mr president i've come to ask you for
support help and justice because i fear
for my life
the spate of killings has put reporters
across mexico on edge
and sparked protests asking the
government to step up protection for
media workers
and for more on this now i want to bring
in javier garza he is a journalist in
mexico and a consultant on journalist
protection at the world association of
newspapers javier it's good to have you
on the program i mean the numbers here
are really bad the fourth killing of a
journalist in mexico this year reporters
without borders says 50 journalists have
been killed over the past five years in
mexico how do you explain what's going
on
hi brent thank you for having me uh it's
really tough to explain
because we are looking at two
main main causes um uh or main reasons
why this is
happening one is uh the
the spree of uh attacks against
journalists not just uh
murders murder is of course the most
extreme
form of attack but threats of every kind
spying harassment surveillance et cetera
the spree of ataxicus journalists that
we have been experiencing for the last
15 years
under different governments so this is
not a problem of the current uh federal
government in mexico this is a problem
that we have been accumulating for years
but it has accelerated under this
government because we are seeing that
contrary to what was promised by by
foreign president andres manuel lopez
obrador who uh got to office with with
the
uh campaign platform of eliminating
corruption and eliminating violence
there is a total lack of commitment uh i
would even say a lack of interest
on the part of the government
for tackling this issue and so this
feels impunity
uh this makes uh crime against
journalists to go unpunished and
everybody who thinks about attacking the
journalists uh can can do so with the
knowledge that uh they can get away with
it and reporters without borders labels
mexico the most dangerous place for
journalists in
the world
and based on what you're saying it
sounds like journalists are being
targeted you know not only from the drug
cartels but also possibly from you know
all the way up to the highest levels of
government
yeah journalists are being targeted from
from multiple sources uh usually it is
draw cartels who carry out the most
extreme form of attack which is the
assassination but we have also been
seeing particularly in the last years
this collusion between
criminal organizations drug cartels or
other criminal organizations and local
government officials
at the municipal or the state level
police forces or other security forces
sort of um
conflate
um in order to uh mask the real purpose
of um
killing a journalist let's say for
example a local authority uh has a
problem with the journalists so
an assassination can be ordered but it
can be outsourced so to speak uh to a
criminal group uh and so it will look
like a hit by a criminal organization so
there's all these different combinations
together and sometimes the government
would minimize um the the um the crimes
by saying well the journalist wasn't
really a journalist because he was
working on something else uh the last
case of robert
we saw a response from the federal
government saying that that he was
working on something else not as a
journalist
and so it gets
very murky
and javier we want to remind our viewers
you work as a security consultant for
other journalists and we expect to hear
that when we're talking about war zones
but we're talking about mexico i mean
what safety advice do you give
journalists who are working in mexico
yeah but i i work on on these issues
because i experienced violence uh myself
as the editor of a newspaper that came
under fire from drug cartels in several
locations so some of the lessons that i
learned is that um
each regional dynamic is very different
what's happening in michoacan where we
have the latest killing uh of a
journalist is very different from
tijuana for example where uh the
case of lourdes maldonado for instance
so we have to get to the bottom of the
local circumstances and what are the
dynamics the criminal dynamics the
political dynamics that fuel violence
against journalists but the advice that
i give journalists is you need to have a
safety protocol a safety plan based on
those local dynamics you really have to
know your turf
and design the appropriate safety
measures and
and unfortunately this is true you
cannot you have to be very uh certain
very aware that you cannot rely on the
government for help because they are not
helping on the contrary sometimes
they're making the problems worse yeah
that is a a tragic commentary on the
security situation also on the state of
government by the people in mexico
javier gartha journalist there in mexico
we appreciate your time and your
insights and stay safe thank you
thank you brent